do you need to be gifted to study
physics I'd say definitely no and
especially not with me
typical definition of the word gifted
which means getting high grades and the
school then I think if referring to
yourself as gifted was a requirement for
studying physics then not many people
and at least definitely the best people
would never do it I think this is flawed
or a flawed idea in a few ways one would
be that definition of gifted and I think
well especially at school the kind of
talents of skills that they're measuring
are only one type of thinking and it's
probably going to be the memorization
and regurgitation type of thinking and
that's not what you need to do good in
the physics
I'd say grades in school are one of the
poorest indicators of how well you'll do
at university a better indicator of
whether you'd do well studying physics
would be are you really curious about
the world and do you really want to
learn more about it if no one can stop
you from wanting to learn more about the
world I don't think you should try to
stop yourself from studying physics
another good indicator would be
resilience because doing physics is hard
I've done a lot of science communication
type things over the years and I love
sharing that curiosity for the world
with people and engaging them with
science but I usually stop one step
short of encouraging them to go and
study it for this degree for themselves
because I feel that for most people it
actually wouldn't be a good fit and it
has nothing to do with how gifted they
are
it sort of do they love it enough to go
through all the hard work that's
involved I've had really gifted friends
drop out of the program plenty of people
I know have had a really hard time
through a lot of science or just some
general university subjects it can be
quite a grinding process so whilst you
don't need to be gifted to study physics
you do need something you need something
a little bit special about you and those
are those qualities I mentioned maybe
even a little bit of madness to want to
do it and to want to do something that
most people consider to be too hard or
too daunting or too boring I've heard
that one a lot what physics really needs
our diverse thinkers when you get down
to the research stage the ability to
think outside of the box is what's going
to help research go forwards and that's
the whole argument with diversity and
why physics needs not only more woman
studying physics both people from
diverse backgrounds and diverse ways of
thinking not just the same sort of skill
measured ways but you know it's it's
hard to know if you're gifted at being
creative especially at school and if
you're trying to study these analytical
subjects then you might not know and you
might not know you're a good fit for
doing research but physics needs you and
physics needs those really different
thinkers